now while Biden is racking up failures
look at this South Dakota shining
example of what good leadership can do
the state is now home to the lowest
unemployment rate in American history
anyway joining us now is South Dakota
Governor Christie Nom is with us
Governor I mean you I not only do you
have the lowest unemployment rate of any
state in history but my understanding is
you have 25
000 job openings that may or may not
require a license or any specific skill
set is that true
is true and we have people that are
interested moving to South Dakota to
fill those jobs and we've done
incredible work to have all licensing
reciprocity so if someone wants to move
to South Dakota needs a license to
practice we will recognize that license
no matter what state they come from
today I announced a historic investment
in apprenticeship programs we will train
teachers in the classroom to be teachers
train plumbers on the job electricians
Barbers cosmetologists whatever requires
a license you can earn a wage while you
get that license and further your career
and Sean what South Dakota is doing is
incredible in spite of the headwinds
that President Biden and his
administration are sending our way we
are being Innovative and it's because
we've given our people the freedom to
make decisions for themselves and when
they bring us Big Ideas we go after them
and make them happen here
let me let me make sure I understand
this so if you have a medical license in
another state you can move to South
Dakota and it would be valid there or
nursing license or any license at all
immediately immediately in fact 3
000 yeah 3 000 jobs immediately that
would be filled today if people decided
to move here we have actually gone out
and identified people across this
country that are interested in moving to
South Dakota uh to fill these open jobs
and we're talking to them about housing
the school system they would like the
community they'd like to be a part of
and specifically individually recruiting
them to come fill our jobs that we have
open because frankly Sean the state that
has the workers the people that get up
every day and go fill these positions
and allow our businesses to be
successful that's the state that's going
to win and our state has been winning
for years since I've been Governor we're
going to continue to do so and set an
example for the country you know there
was a period of time in North Dakota
where they were paying people to train
them to drive a truck because of the in
the energy sector and they would train
them they would house them and they
would make an average of about 100 125
Grand a year many people that were
making 35 40 50 Grand a year you know
moved to North Dakota and they started
making real money and all the overtime
they could handle and those people were
then able to save money buy a house get
a get a new truck get a new car get
whatever they wanted and it literally
transformed their lives so it seems like
some states get it and then other states
don't get it I don't understand the
states with heavy regulation and high
taxes I guess that's why people leave in
those States
I think that's exactly right you know
here in our state incomes are going up
faster than anywhere else in the country
and this year and we didn't raise taxes
we cut them and we don't have an income
tax we don't have a personal property
tax we have a sales tax that was at four
and a half cents uh per dollar we've cut
that down to 4.2 and we cut the
unemployment tax and saved millions of
dollars out of our taxpayers and
businesses Pockets so we're looking for
opportunities to let people keep their
money let them use it in the best way to
help their family they're thriving
because of it Joe Biden's announcement
video was one of the weirdest things
that I've ever seen as far as talking
about it and lack of vision I was
looking at that thinking what is this
guy Define as freedom and if people
really want to see it they need to come
visit us in South Dakota in fact just
pack up and move because you're going to
want to stay here all right you shut me
down the last time but I have to ask the
obligatory question
um and I don't blame you for shutting me
down but there is a lot of talk that you
might be considering getting in to the
presidential race and the nominating
part of the race
are you considering in any way shape
matter form a run for the presidency
I'm super focused here Sean in South
Dakota but I'll tell you this country
cannot afford four more years of Joe
Biden so we need new leadership and
Leadership that loves this country not
one that is literally not healthy that's
not enough you can I don't know if it's
going to do you any good but you sure
can all right well give me a shot uh but
that's not a no would you consider it
are you considering it
it's not a no but also Sean we've got so
many people that are talking about it
and running that I think it's best if I
stay focused where I am and continue to
visit with my family and pray and and do
the best thing that I we think is right
for our family but then also still
continue to serve this country because
we need people that'll step up and do
hard things these days to to solve our
problems so I if I had an answer that
was clear I'd give it to you today I
promise that's a half a no maybe in a
possibility I don't know
anyway Governor thank you we appreciate
you being with us